Now, we want to revisit that
question of information flow.
And remember, recall that
information flow is a problem
that cannot be addressed by
discretionary access control, okay.
So we want to see how mandatory
access control, or MAC, or
multi level security, in particular
the BLP model that we are focusing on.
And so how does the BLP model help us
solve that information flow problem
that we had?
So we say we have an object,
this is a top secret object.
So we have a top secret object 2 is TS.
This is more sensitive information.
We never want this information to go and
end up in an object that
has level is only secret.
So this is more sensitive object.
2 is more sensitive than object 1
because we said TS is greater than S.
So this is highly top
secret information.
We never want it to end up in
an object that is only classified
at the secret level.
Okay, so how can this information
flow from here to there?
There are two paths.
Path one is that a top
secret user reads it.
We know that the read
down rule means what?
For this to read, for
someone to be able to read this,
the user has to be TS,
otherwise they can't read it.
A secret user can only read secret or
below.
So, a top secret user
can read this object.
So, this read will be allowed.
And then they, can this
information that they have pulled,
remember the Alice, Bob, Charlie example
in discretionary access control we had?
Where Alice gave read access to Bob,
who copied the data
into a file that he created and
then passed it on to Charlie?
Well, can User 1 do something like that?
Can it create Object 2,
in which it may be able to
write this information that
it just read from Object 1.
For someone who is not top-secret to
be able to read this information,
the object we create has to be secret or
lower.
TS then is just like here.
They won't be able to read Object 2,
they won't be able to read Object 1.
This object is at the lower level,
then the write rule says what?
You can only write up.
You can't write down.
So all the top secret user can
take this information, read it.
But they're not able to write
it in an object that can be read
by somebody who's not
cleared at top secret.
So this path doesn't allow informational
flow to get to a lower level.
What about a secret user?
We know the secret user can,
once it's here, can read that.
I guess we know that
a secret user can't read.
So, this path we said is not possible.
This path actually ends right here
because the secret user is not able to
read a top secret document.
This label would not dominate
the label of the object.
So this path is broken here,
this path is broken right here,
so this information actually
never flows in here.
And information from Object
1 flowing to Object 2.
Secret can read this object and
can write up, yes.
But that doesn't violate any
confidentiality requirements.
So secret information can now
be read by a top secret person.
This information, made its way from
here, through user 2, into this object.
The top secret could already read this,
read down.
So, in this direction,
information of flow doesn't make
more sensitive information available to
a user, who is cleared at a lower level.
The system would not allow information
that is read from this object
to be written into an object
that is at the lower level.
That's a guarantee
that comes with BLP and
the MAC model that we didn't
have with DAC before.
So this is how we're able to control
information flow, and that's how we
fix one of the shortcomings that we
had with discretionary access control.